Recent lesions found in my liver and many small tumors in my spine and pelvic.
Dr. Not concerned much about the small ones yet.
I get severe pain with being on my feet too much as in normal day activity.
What do you recommend for pain?
What does low damage to the liver or stomach?
Well, whatever you have pain, you always want to find out why.
So whatever you have a symptom, you don't just want to find out how you can take the symptom and make it go away.
You want to find out why the symptoms are there.
So if the pain in your a bead on your feet too much as in normal day activity is from the tumor.
If it's from a tumor or a testesis into your spine, you want to address that.
So you don't want to magically, even if you could, make that pain go away because then you wouldn't be getting the signal that something you wrote.
So you do want to address that.
If you have a testesis of the spine and it is causing pain, you do want to address that.
And that's where I would suggest that radiation might be an option if that's what they've talked to you about.
And it might be a good option because what you could do spot radiation on a bone, many times you could kill the cancer that's in that bone.
Not a big fan of radiation to soft tissue, but radiation to bone could be really life saving in a lot of different ways.